every time tour-guide Paulo patoot so
crosses the rialto bridge he can't help
but wonder where did his charming City
go the one that's now overrun with
millions of tourists
how can Venice protect itself from the
onslaught of visitors he's sure this
piece of world cultural heritage won't
survive as a photo backdrop alone
sipping subtly my love for this city
makes me seek out places and people who
are keeping Venice alive because there
are enough people who are
counter-steering
and navigating the city into troubled
waters quested arizona kay'est
aprendiendo nachita like most Venetians
Powler lives from tourism which presents
him with a dilemma
he now conducts special tours to draw
attention to the city's problems like in
his own district where rents are rising
as flats are being used as holiday homes
more and more Venetians are moving away
at the bar Paulo frequents Venice's
decline is a hot topic 20 years ago the
city was full of craftspeople who
produced things for the local people
upholsterers carpenters locksmiths
bookbinders they're all gone today no
one makes mattresses or repairs shoes
anymore and that's wounded Venetians
pride is this all that's left of their
once so prosperous trading city Paulo
shows us the mercado de Rialto the old
fish and vegetable market now it's just
a tourist trap Venice has become a city
in which few people actually live here
there are more tourists taking photos
than paying customers that provokes
people which is why a few fish mongers
are considering asking for money to pose
for photos in front of this tourist
backdrop I got a figure on T the cruise
ships are also a huge problem activist
Stefano Nicoletti is outraged not only
do these huge vessels flood the city
with day-trippers they're also
threatening the lagoon
city's very foundations show movimiento
de la liga provoker the big ships
propellers have a piston effect they
chine up all the subsoil so clay and
silt from the lagoon are gradually
washed into the open sea
as a result Venice a city built on
wooden piles is slowly sinking and could
eventually be completely underwater
but Nicoletti isn't giving up his
citizens initiative has managed to
prevent even more cruise ships from
coming into Venice when a ship like that
goes by the water level in the nearby
canals sinks by around 20 centimeters
and then rises again right afterwards
due to the displacement this hugely
powerful force eats away at the
foundations of the palaces churches and
bridges but not everyone in Venice is
happy about my coletti's initiative the
port authorities invested millions of
euros in modern cruise terminals now due
to the success of the protests only half
of them can be used for years we've been
listening to these fears that our ships
could even ram into Venice I can only
keep reassuring people even with the
biggest ships the chances of that
happening are zero so the industry is
still fighting to keep the huge ships
cruising by st. Mark's Square it's a
business worth millions
but resistance is growing also due to
the exhaust fumes the ship's release
into the air more and more Venetians
feel their city is not on the right
course so far big construction projects
have been decided by the corporations
operating the port in the airport it's
only about growth ever bigger evermore
as for the city's welfare there's no
strategy whatsoever that makes Paolo
patoot so both angry and sad each year
Venice is 55 thousand residents are
overrun by 30 million tourists many
think the time has come for radical
counter strategies it's paradoxical but
the best
for Venice is the one who stays at home
we're more than full up with 30 million
visitors a year it's clear something
must be done to reduce the number of
visitors to a reasonable figure but for
that to happen
Venetians will have to sacrifice some
tourist dollars to save their beloved
City